تنضم الان الينا من انقره مراسلتنا فرح
الزمان شوقي اهلا فرح اذا ضعنا في صوره
تفاصيل ما نشره الجانبان التركي والامريكي
واذا كانت هناك اي معلومات اضافيه عن
كواليس الاجتماع
تفضلي ليى في الحقيقه اجتماع وزير
الخارجيه التركي ونظيره الامريكي داما
لفتره زادت عن ساعتين بعد ذلك اجتمع
الوزير الامريكي بالرئيس التركي الاجتماع
باجتماع زادت مدته عن ساعه تقريبا الكثير
من التفاصيل وتنتهي هذه الزياره دون مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك وببيان يصدر عن الخارجيه
التركيه فقط وفي الحقيقه هذا البيان يؤشر
الى نقاط لطالما اعلنت عنها تركيا فيما
يتعلق بموقفها من الحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه تتحدث الخارجيه التركيه هنا عن
ضروره تحقيق وقف فوري لاطلاق النار اصا
المساعدات الانسانيه الى غزه ولكن بشكل
مستمر كذلك تتحدث هنا او بحسب وصف
الخارجيه الى ضروره وقف ما تصفه بالعدائية
لكن على جانب اخر هنالك الكثير من الملفات
المتقاطعه التي من الممكن ان تكون قد وضعت
على الطاوله التركيه الامريكيه في
الاجتماعين مع الرئيس او مع وزير الخارجيه
التركي منها ما يتعلق بالوساطه التي كانت
قد اقترحتها انقره في وقت سابق سابق فيما
يرتبط باطلاق سراح المحتجزين الموجودين
لدى حماس في قطاع غزه الى جانب المسائل
السياسيه الثانيه التي تحدثت عنها انقره
فدان قد يكون قد وضع بلينكن بصوره تطورات
اجتماعات اللجنه المسماه باللجنه السباعيه
المنبثقه عن منظمه التعاون الاسلامي والتي
تجري اجتماعات تتعلق كذلك بالحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه وهنا ليله اود ان
اشير كذلك الى نقطه في الايام الاخيره
الماضيه اعتقلت السلطات التركيه مجموعه من
الافراد يحملون جنسيات مختلفه قالت انهم
على صله بالموساد وكانوا يدبرون لعمليات
لربما عمليات امنيه هنا في تركيا هذا
الملف ايضا قد يكون قد وضع على الطاوله
التركيه الامريكيه لا سما ان المسؤولين في
انقره كانوا قد صرحوا مرارا بان تركيا
ستقف ضد اي عمل امني قد يهدد امنها ولربما
يستهدف اعضاء من حماس من المتواجدين على
اراضيها لذلك هي ملفات كثيره في الحقيقه
سواء تلك التي شرحت في بيان الخارجيه
التركيه او حتى المتعلقه بموا قف سابقه
بينهما لكن على الخط الموازي ليلى ايضا
الملفات كثيره بين الطرفين سواء مقاتلات
اف 16 او عضويه السويد في النيتو والتي
تؤكد تركيا اليوم بان هذا القرار يرجع الى
البرلمان التركي لا سما بعد موافقه لجنه
السياسه الخارجيه على هذه العضويه ملف
روسيا واوكرانيا والكثير الكثير هذه ليست
الزياره الاولى لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي
الى تركيا بعد الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه
هي الزياره الثانيه ولكنه هذه المره يلتقي
الرئيس التركي في المره الماضيه لم يلتق
وتنتهي بهذا البيان الذي يؤكد على المواقف
التركيه ولم يكن هناك مؤتمر صحفي بشكل
سريع هل هذا
معتاد في المره الماضيه ايضا لم يكن هنالك
مؤتمر صحفي مشترك بين وزيري الخارجيه
التركي والامريكي وقيل في حينه ايضا ان
هذا الامر قد يتعلق بتشنجات وتوتر معين
بين الطرفين التركي والامريكي اقتصر الامر
في حينه على ايجاز صحفي للوزير الامريكي
خلال مغادرته لانقره اليوم تصدر الخارجيه
فقط بيانا كما ذكرت لك لي